it is time for drew's news your cozy
good new scarf keeping that little draft
of bad news off your neck we won't have
that here there it is and with me at the
desk is my intrepid co-pilot rossi ross
matthews hi everybody
first steps in the news we've all been
celebrating the life of the american
comedy legend betty white
and now the miami herald reports that a
new campaign
is spreading in her honor it's called
the betty white challenge and on january
17th which would be her 100th birthday
fans are donating five dollars to an
animal charity of their choice in
betty's name or
going and actually adopting an animal
and betty always said
that if she wasn't in show business
she'd be a zookeeper
um i have to say
when i think of betty white she is
synonymous with pet rescue
and so
i was watching you know all these things
i loved watching this one thing
where they just said you know why do you
think that you resonate with people so
much and she's like you know i can't see
myself that way which is so humble and
what we love about her she said but i
will say
that i just think that kindness
is everything
and
i think if we could honor that kindness
by supporting the things she loved and
believed in and cared about the most
um you know
rescuing animals and taking care of our
four-legged friends and what if you
adopt one and name it
thing we've betty
ever there's gonna be like a million
little kitties and puppies named betty
just running around and she would love
that i currently have um
do the math five rescues at home yeah so
i'm gonna donate five dollars
i love it and i'm not letting my
children know about this challenge at
all
well you know betty did so much good and
and people recently shared some of
betty's secret to a long life we should
all aim to live like she did and at the
top of her list she says accentuate the
positive that was important to her focus
on what is positive and i love this one
too enjoy your junk food yeah betty
loved red vines potato chips hot dogs
and vodka sandra bullock said in honor
of betty white i'm going to have a hot
dog and a vodka tonight
and
well she also loves
according to people she also loved red
vines and potato chips and we have them
right here yeah we gotta live like betty
white a little bit i don't know if this
is weird but whenever i would get red
vines at the movie theater i love to
whip people with them
feel it
it kind of hurts right it's kind of dark
stop it i know ow
it hurts more than i thought it would
work it's fun to go to the movie theater
though and surprise your uh
friend with pain
just a little whip
you are so twisted
you know what i love about betty white
betty white walked through this earth
for nearly a hundred years and told us
all to be good people
but to enjoy ourselves and laugh and i
think the tone of her life
is as perfect of a life
that i've ever seen as long as i've been
alive
and i'm just
grateful to betty white because we're
all better for her having been on this
planet absolutely that's a legacy
that is illegal betty white is a tone
and a life
all of her own
yeah i know i'll never forget her you
know i got to meet her a few times and
she was so wonderful i got to work with
her and she was just so kind and giving
when like she's betty white and i was
like
you know do you have any betty white
stories well she was just she would come
on the tonight show a lot and remember i
worked on the tonight show with jay leno
back are you kidding me hello
yes and she um she would come on and we
would shoot these scenes together and
you know we did like 900 things in a day
so we would show up and be like what are
we doing now and she was right there
knew her lines knew her mark she was
like the total pro always and she was
like 85 at the time and i mean i
remember thinking like uh that's how you
do it that is how you do it i don't
think there's anybody like her no and if
you can do it with red vines potato
chips vodka and a hot dog
you're living your best life i know i
love that she loved junk food too i know
you we eat just a little bit of junk
food around here i don't know if you
noticed
well next we have a spicy little rumor
that's heating up online okay anyone
here miss kim cattrall on the new sex in
the city and just like that any you
missing her
yeah it's weird without her for sure
well if you're missing samantha jones in
style reports she may be back in a
crossover event on the next season of
emily in paris let me explain here are
the connections emily in paris was
created by darren starr who also created
sex in this oh that's right i didn't
even put that together yes and the
fabulous costumes are done by legendary
patricia field who also did the costumes
on sex in the city for all those years
that's right and both emily and samantha
work in pr and happen to be living in
europe right now so connect the dots do
the math carry the one crossover it
could happen
do you think that all of a sudden
samantha could be in paris
so i have a theory that i think at the
end of and just like that
kim cattrall as samantha jones is going
to make one appearance all right because
if you're watching you see they keep
texting carrie keeps texting samantha it
wouldn't be the biggest pop culture
moment of all time if all of a sudden
last episode of the season
boom samantha's back i think that would
be in the words of paris hilton hot that
would be
huge yeah that would be it kind of it
wants that too it needs to happen all
right well finally i don't remember the
first pizza i ever had but i'm pretty
sure it was love at first bite i mean
it's carbs cheese and tomato why
wouldn't it be but this little baby is
going viral on tick-tock newsweek
reports a mom named steph kimball posted
this video of her daughter sally taking
her first bite of pizza
you cannot even handle look at how cute
this is look at her
[Music]
oh my god no
can you stand it oh my god
oh welcome to the club baby i mean come
on ross
[Applause]
it's kind of like put your chin up
no okay now eat pizza like samantha
jones
i can't do that on television
[Applause]
honey
i'm just saying oh this pizza is really
doing something
i haven't had a hot slice like this and
no i'm not going to say it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i don't know if it's the pizza or the
samantha but
i'm happy
[Music]